une ambiance inégalable
le 21 mars 2018 c'est en forêt qu'il
fallait être pour sa journée
internationale a mare longue c'est un
philippe une sensibilisation ont été
organisées pour les jeunes générations
suite et à l'écorcé rouge
il ya de trop c'est par là vous avez un
mois d'euros personnellement ça nous
permet de sortir le dimanche 2-2 s'aérer
l'esprit un peu et de d'apprendre des
choses sur la nature ben c'est un moyen
de s'évader un moyen de vivre avec la
nature un peu les oiseaux les espèces
endémiques
donc ça sert à apprendre un peu de
liberté en fait de se retrouver soi-même
des milliers d'espèces entourent alors
nos visiteurs une richesse unique et
exceptionnel qui donne un caractère
unique à notre île un lieu à regarder
dans toutes ses dimensions département
possède 95 60 des forêts réunionnaises
et s'en occupe il s'en préoccupent et au
quotidien et
mais aussi dans son budget 20 millions
d'euros pour protéger restaurer
sauvegarde et sensibiliser pour une
gestion durable de ses forêts de nos
forêts donc qu'elles participent à cette
journée c'était indispensable
gestionnaire du domaine lohan est faite
au quotidien dans la forêt afin qu'elle
soit aussi un vecteur social
on aime bien venir en pique nique on
aime bien trouver des sentiers de
randonnée mais
il faudrait qu'on se l'approprient un
cette notion de préservation cette
notion de fragilité
il faut que le grand public soit
vraiment aux côtés de des partenaires et
du gestionnaire qui font de gros efforts
pour porter avec eux le message et moi
je dis toujours ce canton on protège
mieux quand on connaît mieux et comme
tout le monde le sait ensemble on va
plus loin
bien des acteurs participent à la vie de
la forêt est d'avis général
la première chose essentielle semble
d'en profiter